[Música]
[Aplausos]
soy doctor en medicina y cirugía
especialista en cirugía cardiovascular y
catedrático de ingeniería biomédica
llevo formándome investigando trabajando
e innovando en el campo de la cirugía y
de la biotecnología desde los años 80
fui pionero en el campo de las arritmias
creando la primera unidad de cirugía de
arritmias en edad pediátrica de europa
en los años 90
posteriormente me formé en
criopreservación tisular y desarrollé la
primera unidad de injertos aórtico si
pulmonares criopreservados a nivel
europeo iniciando gracias a ello el
programa de cirugía cardíaca neonatal
con la técnica de norwood en españa'
me especialicé en el campo de los
trasplantes y en el año 94 realicé el
primer trasplante de corazón en un
recién nacido de españa' creando la
primera unidad de trasplantes cardíacos
pediátricos en el país
también me especialicé en el campo de la
asistencia ventricular y en el corazón
artificial e implante en el año 2006 el
primer corazón artificial externo
biventricular mecánico en un niño en
españa'
más recientemente me he formado en
ingeniería tisular y tecnologías
auditivas en células madre y en cirugía
cardíaca robótica con el método da vinci
pero hoy no he venido a hablaros de
todos estos avances ni de cirugías
complejas reparadoras y reconstructivas
pura cirugía que yo llamo de
arquitectura ingeniería cardiovascular
hoy voy a hablaros de algo muy antiguo y
a la vez de algo muy nuevo vengo a
hablaros de un nuevo concepto de
medicina de precisión y del nuevo cambio
de paradigma en el que vivimos
alejándonos de las reglas clásicas de la
medicina tradicional y caminando hacia
una nueva medicina la medicina de la
complejidad una medicina con integración
de la genómica junto con las tecnologías
derivadas de la ingeniería biomédica una
medicina de precisión y personalizada
una medicina que integra conceptos de
medicina predictiva realizada mediante
la secuenciación genética y que nos
informa acerca de la mayor o menor
posibilidad y susceptibilidad de padecer
cierto tipo de enfermedad es una
medicina que integra conceptos de
medicina preventiva y que podemos
ejercer en aquellos casos detectados de
susceptibilidad genética del desarrollo
de cualquier tipo de patologías
una medicina personalizada basada en la
información obtenida del código genético
del propio individuo una medicina de
precisión enfocada a las características
de la propia naturaleza de la persona
una medicina proactiva donde la persona
juega un papel primordial involucrándose
en su autocuidado y en su relación con
el entorno y la epigenética
y finalmente una medicina participativa
al poder compartir parte de nuestra
propia información previamente analizada
obtenida mediante las nuevas
herramientas de gestión como la minería
de datos y la inteligencia artificial en
beneficio del gran colectivo humano
en definitiva vengo a hablaros de un
nuevo concepto de medicina totalmente
interactiva que ya está cambiando y que
cambiará todavía más en los próximos
años el mundo de la salud potenciando
tanto el incremento de la longevidad de
las personas como lo más importante su
calidad de vida
estamos de lleno a la tercera gran
revolución de la humanidad estamos
inmersos en la era del big data la
minería de datos y la inteligencia
artificial y tenemos una gran
responsabilidad social al poder
optimizar toda esa información al
beneficio no sólo del propio individuo
sino también de toda la humanidad
caminemos hacia este nuevo cambio de
paradigma de la medicina
desciframos nuestros códigos genéticos y
estudiemos los cambios que en la
genética producen los factores
ambientales es decir la epigenética sólo
así podremos vivir más años y unos años
de vida realmente ajustados a la calidad
el secreto de la longevidad de las
personas sus potenciales enfermedades y
su calidad de vida está escrita en sus
genes está contenida condensada y
codificada en tan solo cuatro letras
tg
estas cuatro letras que representan la
adenina citosina timina y guanina son
nuestras bases nitrogenadas compuestos
químicos que se encargan de darle la
especificidad y el carácter básico a los
ácidos nucleicos que se encuentran
dentro de nuestro adn
estas cuatro letras tienen funciones
esenciales en la replicación del
material genético en la transcripción
genética participando en la síntesis de
proteínas y en nuestro metabolismo
celular
en el caso de los seres humanos el adn
donde se encuentran almacenadas estas
cuatro letras estos cuatro nucleótidos
es una cadena de aproximadamente dos
metros de longitud que se encuentra
fuertemente empaquetada formando los
cromosomas contenidos en el núcleo de
todas y cada una de nuestras células y
que forman el genoma humano
este genoma humano contiene información
para construir más de 25.000 proteínas
proteínas que entre otras muchas
funciones son las encargadas de llevar a
cabo las funciones celulares desde la
organización de la división celular es
decir la supervivencia celular a
dirigirse a puntos distantes del
organismo en forma de hormonas para así
poder regular otras células
por lo tanto determinar el grupo de
proteínas que cada célula va a tener en
cada momento requiere una regulación muy
delicada y es algo vital para poder
definir la vida y para definir la
diferenciación celular y decidir si una
célula va a ser una neurona o por el
contrario una célula cardíaca y para que
la célula sepa cuántas veces debe
dividirse antes de morir o para que
desarrollen otra determinada función en
un preciso instante
en determinadas células hay una serie de
genes que siempre han de mantenerse
silenciados otros que han de mantenerse
siempre activos y un último grupo que se
activa o se desactiva en función de las
necesidades de esa célula como reacción
al entorno
esta concepción molecular de la vida
descubrir el lenguaje que utilizan las
células nos proporciona una imagen
precisa y detallada de las piezas que
forman el ser humano y de las leyes que
rigen su funcionamiento
todos nuestros futuros secretos nuestros
rasgos físicos nuestras características
particulares de confort y bienestar y
nuestra susceptibilidad y predisposición
genética a desarrollar determinadas
enfermedades están escritos en nuestros
genes en nuestro libro de la vida
el libro donde radica el conjunto
completo de instrucciones genéticas
necesarias para construir en definitiva
todo lo que constituye lo que es un ser
humano
estamos en una etapa de la evolución de
la humanidad privilegiada de una manera
sencilla y asequible mediante una simple
muestra de sangre e incluso de saliva
tenemos el poder y la posibilidad real
de secuenciar y leer este código
complejo tenemos la capacidad de
predecir desde nuestros rasgos físicos
como la altura el color de los ojos e
incluso nuestra edad biológica y a poder
predecir nuestra mayor o menor
susceptibilidad y predisposición a
determinadas enfermedades
tenemos también la capacidad de
personalizar los tratamientos en caso de
desarrollar ciertas enfermedades tanto
cardiovasculares como incluso el cáncer
y en un futuro próximo con las nuevas
técnicas de edición genética tendremos
la capacidad de poder cortar y modificar
la secuencia de nuestro adn
en definitiva podremos editar y corregir
el genoma de cualquier célula del cuerpo
humano
toda esta información todos estos miles
de millones de datos los tenemos
condensados y agrupados dentro de esta
estructura cristalina llamada de n
estructura que hay podemos secuenciar de
forma masiva y sencilla gracias a una
simple foto tomada por rosalind franklin
hace más de 50 años
esta secuenciación del genoma puede
llegar a cambiar el paradigma de la
longevidad de la enfermedad y de los
tratamientos médicos y cambiar en
definitiva la calidad de vida del ser
humano
estamos en la era de una medicina de
precisión y personalizada una medicina
más correcta enfocada para una persona
concreta en un determinado momento
indicado medicina que será rutinaria
dentro de n años estamos entrando en la
era de abandonar y dejar de realizar la
medicina generalizada que venimos
realizando una misma medicina para todos
con los mismos tratamientos una medicina
de menú cerrado que hemos visto que
muchas veces no funciona de una manera
individualizada y estamos entrando en
una medicina con un menú a la carta con
aplicación de terapias y tratamientos de
precisión totalmente individualizados y
personalizados
pero no se trata de estudiar solo
nuestros genes hay que estudiar también
nuestros hábitos hay que estudiar la
proteómica y la exposición al ambiente
en definitiva estudiar como la
epigenética la metilación del adn las
modificaciones de las histonas los
cambios en la cromatina y los micro rn
no codificantes influyen en nuestro
organismo pudiendo alterar nuestra
predisposición genética
conocer en detalle los mecanismos
epigenéticos que están implicados en
cada persona y en cada enfermedad y
desarrollar herramientas y técnicas para
poder modificarlos permitirá mejorar el
curso clínico de las enfermedades y en
muchos casos llegar a curarlas
los avances en este campo de la medicina
son incesantes y muy prometedores en la
actualidad hay varios ensayos clínicos
en marcha utilizando agentes que
modifican la metilación del adn que
cambian las propiedades de las histonas
o que modifican la actividad de los
micro rn no codificantes e incluso
algunos utilizan varias estrategias es'
y genéticas combinadas
no somos solo nuestros genes ellos son
solamente una parte de nuestra historia
también somos fruto de nuestra
epigenética epigenética que actúa de
regulador a nivel genético y que añade
más complejidad pero a la vez permite
entender mucho mejor cómo funciona
nuestro organismo humano
si la genética nos hizo comprender
nuestro destino como seres vivos y ver
que lo que podemos llegar a ser ya está
escrito en nuestros genes antes del
nacimiento la epigenética ha venido a
demostrarnos que lo que está escrito se
puede cambiar
si bien la información a nivel genético
sigue siendo imprescindible hoy en día
la epigenética desde una perspectiva
superior proporciona una información
mucho más precisa y válida
esta interacción entre el entorno y
nuestra genética no solo a nivel celular
sino incluso con carácter
transgeneracional es una faceta
estimulante y promete ser algo realmente
impactante cuando seamos capaces de
comprenderlo en toda su complejidad
actualmente se está estudiando como
estas marcas afectan a la actividad
génica para poder fabricar nuevas
herramientas de diagnóstico y de
seguimiento de multitud de patologías
enfermedades ya sean de origen genético
ambiental o multifactorial incluso se
están empezando a utilizar fármacos
capaces de alterar la actividad de los
reguladores epigenéticos con el fin de
revertir las alteraciones que se
observan algunos estados patológicos y
restablecer los patrones normales
el conocimiento de la base genética ha
supuesto un gran cambio en nuestra
concepción de la vida y la enfermedad
podemos revertir los efectos del
ambiente y modular la epigenética nos
llevará a poder atacar la enfermedad
desde un punto de vista más específico
dando paso realmente a lo que se conoce
como medicina de precisión personalizada
y hemos entrado de lleno en la era de la
medicina de la complejidad
medicina la que podemos integrar toda
nuestra información genética junto con
los demás biomarcadores moleculares y
serológicos tradicionales y unir toda
esa información y conocimiento con toda
la información obtenida con las
tecnologías más avanzadas de diagnóstico
por imágenes sólo así de este modo
podremos detectar enfermedades en etapas
mucho más precoces de desarrollo
estamos de lleno en una etapa del
desarrollo de la medicina donde la
valoración de la susceptibilidad
genética la predicción y la prevención
juegan un papel muy importante podemos y
debemos de actuar de manera preventiva y
esa prevención debe personalizarse
la vida es un programa de aprendizaje y
parte de este programa aprendizaje está
escrito nuestros genes y el código para
poder interpretar ese programa está
disponible con la secuenciación del adn
nuestros genes representan cientos de
millones de años de evolución y de
diferentes estrategias de supervivencia
por lo tanto me pregunto qué pasaría si
pudiera saber exactamente cómo los
alimentos el ambiente o determinados
medicamentos pueden afectar a mi salud
seamos inteligentes y aprovechemos todo
este conocimiento de información que
tenemos oculto y almacenado en nuestras
células aprovechemos la valiosa herencia
que nuestra genética nos ha
proporcionado
estamos en la era de la integración de
la medicina con la ingeniería biomédica
estamos en la era de desarrollo de
nuevos tratamientos personalizados
incluidas inmunoterapias tratamientos
con interleuquinas interferones terapias
de células t con receptores de antígenos
quiméricos terapias con células madres
reprogramadas e incluso tratamientos con
virus oncolíticos
estamos en la era donde podemos
reprogramar células de la piel para que
actúen como células madre pluripotentes
embrionarias y poder usarlas
potencialmente para tratar diferentes
patologías
podemos crear nuestras propias líneas de
células madre personalizadas que podemos
incluso guardar criopreservada
tendremos nuestros propios bancos de
células cardíacas y células neuronales
para usarlas en el futuro en caso de
necesitarlas
estamos en una era donde podemos
integrar todo esto con la ingeniería
celular usando tecnologías auditivas
para mediante la impresión celular 3d y
4d podría llegar a construir desde
prótesis personalizadas a órganos
biológicos y de mecánicos
estamos en la era de la medicina de
precisión de la computación ubicua y la
inteligencia ambiental en una etapa de
desarrollo de la inteligencia artificial
y de la explotación del big data a
través de herramientas como la minería
de datos
estamos en la era de un gran desarrollo
de la nanotecnología y de los orígenes
todavía incipientes de la terapia génica
terapia génica tanto somática mediante
transformación in vivo porque es vivo
como terapia génica germinal
estamos en un cambio de paradigma
alejándonos de la medicina empírica
imprecisa y de ensayo-error estamos
entrando en la era de la farmacogenómica
la era de saber cuál es el medicamento
más apropiado en base a la información
genética y de cuál es incluso la dosis y
la combinación correcta
estamos en la era de poder crear e
imprimir mediante tecnología aditiva
nuestros propios fármacos personalizados
caminemos hacia este nuevo cambio de
paradigma de la medicina
desciframos nuestros códigos genéticos y
estudiemos como estos pueden ser
alterados por la epigenética
sólo así podremos vivir más años y
alcanzar esa longevidad tan anhelada por
el ser humano pero una longevidad con la
mejor calidad de vida posible de acuerdo
con el concepto de wally
vivamos más año de vida pero más años de
vida ajustados
[Música]
[Aplausos]